you're getting it done still you know I
don't think so you guys my life is
falling apart it was a pun it does feel
like that sometimes though but it's good
though we're all making it work right
guys let's [__] change the
[Music]
subject welcome back to careful boys
where we are afraid of everything which
pivots perfectly into my next topic
check out the merch afraid of everything
what is the most recent thing that made
you
cry oh [__]
damn go boys [__] dude I don't even
actually remember when I phys like
physically cried but I do remember the
last time I cried in my dream so hard
that it felt real let's go I was in all
this is going to be stupid cuz I was
like in Walmart and then I felt lost in
your dream yeah in Walmart I was lost in
Walmart and I couldn't get out of
Walmart and then it was terrifying wait
did this happen to you as a kid though
if you think about it no I get lost as a
kid and my mom would purposely lose me
cuz she thought it was funny to watch me
panic and then she would pop out of
nowhere and be like I've been here the
whole time so it did happen to you as a
kid yeah but it was funny no no no yeah
at the mall and all that [__] cuz I
would wander around and [__] so she was
like all right [__] she's
teaching you yeah she's yeah but then it
would backfire too cuz I would just
wander around and then when I am
actually lost I just know to go to a
security guard and have them call my
mom's name and then we meet up nice yeah
but yeah that was a the last time I
think was a terrifying dream it was like
rational fear of like Walmart I love
Walmart but then it's like a dream right
you're like oh yeah I'm shopping at
Walmart there's all this cool [__] going
on and then it's like I can't get out
like I'm pushing the shopping cart I'm
like where the [__] is the exit and I
like I'm forever stuck in Walmart and I
just like start balling cuz I'm like I
can't [__] leave this place yeah damn
brude but that was kind of stupid for
your sleep I get it but that's that's
vulnerable but that was a yeah that was
the last time I don't know what it's
supposed to mean yeah what would a dream
interpreter say I know like you shop at
Walmart too much D oh do you shop at w
Walmart too I'm almost there like every
week oh [__] Walmart and Costco my two
favorite stores yeah Walmart's pretty
tight though I'm so American
yeah I cried last Sunday last Sunday oh
that's early what do you mean last
Sunday that's the most recent so far
let's go most recent Sunday oh yeah I uh
context uh I got married a year ago but
on my anniversary which was this past
Saturday uh we ended up finally throwing
my family wedding which is Chinese
vietamese we did a tea ceremony nice I
know I know did that in Vegas no we we
did this in in OC we did we went to went
to my parents house and I had to like
you know get on my knees and ser te to
my elders and same with Nina and stuff
like that wow they gave me Ley you know
they gave me red envelopes uh and then
we ended up going to you know a [__]
Diamond Plaza Seafood number two or some
[__] like one of those super Asian
places with 10 course SE Seafood type
offering the food was bomb even though I
only ate like [__] three Plates
Irvine no no no no no in way more ghetto
Westminster um and uh we ate there and
uh we had that family wedding but this
was one of those things where it's like
we had eloped a year ago nobody was
there now we had a like family wedding
so all the cousins and like all my
parents friends and people I don't know
and stuff like we're there but we never
got a chance to celebrate with what our
friends are what would have been our
brdal party so we went out to Vegas we
flew immediately after that went to
Vegas and just [__] partied all
weekend but we ended up having a uh we
wanted to do a vow renewal or another
ceremony at an Elvis style Las Vegas
Chapel where Elvis walks Nina down the
aisle and he sings a bunch of songs and
stuff like that that's so tight lot of f
Steve was there was best yeah Steve was
there that's funny cuz me and Bart was
actually in Vegas but we didn't get
invited wouldn't miss it wouldn't miss
it I didn't know you were there I
invited him he didn't make cuz he's not
a cool friend yeah not a good friend
I'll tell you why after you're going to
feel so bad I already know why I got the
explanation I was supposed to be I was
supposed to be in LA with Bart No One
Ever Knows where you are Joe that's true
and you never invite me to your wedding
things there's only been one I ran into
to him outside my place the other day no
way wait your place yeah oh yeah I was
at I was yeah I saw him in his truck by
his house what was he doing what were
you doing at his house my friend built a
is building a warehouse near his house
so I was out there and he pulls up and I
and cuz we were talking about Ryan we're
like oh Ryan lives right here and then
that's Ryan and my friend ding from
Cambodia you're just hanging out with
your Cambodian friend who's building
warehouses see nobody knows where you're
ever at I thought you
Hawaii you're very unpredictable yeah
that Saturday being by the way I had a
friend in town by the way no excuses
since I got this [__] tattoo there's
no excuses anymore there is no [__]
like ask Anthony he already has asked me
for a favor since we got this I
prioritized that before I did any of my
[__] and I went above and beyond already
what was that I won't say what it is not
giving you guys [__] you guys what it
[__] all right just don't give me [__]
just saying okay exes that being said uh
after after this uh ceremony uh we had a
luncheon which you couldn't make it too
could make it had a friend in town it's
all good sucked but so you guys have
matching tattoos you're going to put
them everything no no no I I showed up
that that's quoting out of context or
that's perfectly in context and that's
maybe [__] up I don't know I'm not and
it was during a Colts game and I'm a
writer and it was Colts Rams it was a
[__] tie game in halftime so the
Colts didn't win Nick did Anthony invite
you no it's it's pretty interesting cuz
I while everyone's like oh I didn't get
I I couldn't go I'm just sitting here
like oh I guess I'll just go [__] speak
speaking of fear what I fear is him
rejecting me CU he always turns us down
single time again it's a fear thing okay
that being said it's rude uh we go to
this there's I think there's a beautiful
moment of the story I forget what it was
find it you'll find it we go to this
luncheon at Fogo toow oh I love Fogo
toow thank you that was the beautiful
part he could have gone thank you for
reminding me that's the beautiful part
did you get the cheese with the uh honey
on it what dude they have cheese they I
I'll shut up it's not you want to F go
to CH in Vegas yeah in Vegas they give
you this grilled cheese and they put
[__] honey on it dude it's [__] no
they don't I looked it up they don't no
Steve [__] you dude it's on there keep
are you deflecting My Own Story okay
keep going I'm just telling what I like
that's all he's going to S tell us a
beautiful moment okay I'm it's I think
it's coming around it is and we get
there and I had again we had never
celebrated with our friends so I uh I
had asked both my cousin who I grew up
with and then Mike who obviously is my
my Bes song to uh to just prepare a
toast they can they can make a quick
short toast they make a I I wasn't
worried about that and then there was
definitely uh my cousin obviously
[__] railed on me for my childhood
stories and stuff like that which was
great I love him for that do we need to
jump him no uh Mike though Mike was you
know he he had prepared he's very very
articulate and well worded and when he
got to the saying stuff about he like
built up all this stuff a little bit of
[__] talking a little bit of like you
know praising my characters Stu but only
in order to transition that into why
Nino was awesome and when he got to that
transition that's nice man started
tearing up and [__] that's tight was it
Mike that made you cry yeah it's very
beautiful very very good he really cares
about you huh he does he loves me uh but
yeah I definitely was physically for
real crying this past Sunday nice is
that when we uh accidentally released
the fear no one t-shirt tattoo video
promo too early and then uh you guys
were all so you were doing that whole
wedding thing and then you just in the
group chat like yeah Hey where's Joe it
was that night but yeah we were riding
that yeah we were trying to find you and
figure out what the [__] was going on I
was at Bart house we were talking in a
Jacuzzi for like 5 hours sick you guys
were both chilling in Vegas I don't have
I I I I don't I didn't even have
reception at his house so even if you
invited me I wouldn't have got it who
else was crying I was crying I'll tell
you why
[__] so originally cuz the story
that you know it was uh that weekend was
Gio's 40th birthday that's right which
is why we cuz he did invite us while cuz
he him thinking we're going to be in
Vegas we could join but it was Gio's
40th birthday and so I booked the Airbnb
to kind of get away with her and and
have her be with her closest friends for
her 40th birthday that's why Joe was
supposed to be in LA to and it was
supposed to be it was it was all planned
out back in [__] July or August I
already booked the Airbnb yep on when
was it so I would have said no to you
anyway Anthony because I had commitments
with Bart and Gio like I said fear fear
of rejection that was that that was that
was all like after so Wednesday or
Thursday um so taica has been seizure
free for like a whole year it's a big
deal and so slowly we started weeding
him off his medication because the
doctor said it was it was cool and so we
started weaning him off cuz last time we
wanted this kid taking all kinds of
chemicals he went from two medications
on one medication we're going from one
medication trying to go to zero the
first week that we started to have zero
medication that Wednesday is when he had
a seizure again D so go pick him up
obviously freaks Gio out like crazy we
don't know if it's going to be a
repetitive pattern because it's one of
those things where like you take the
medication to kind of rewire their
circuitry uh cuz if it's if you don't
rewire it it's one of those things where
they can have multiple seizures over and
over and over and it gets faster and
faster and faster so that's how we canel
the whole trip and that's how we ended
up staying in Vegas so that we can
monitor him we didn't take him to school
the next
day that's fake that's fake that's real
hey he's crying right now hey that's
[__]
up don't do that dude sometimes you cry
up here don't do
that you're in
space you're upside down they're seizure
tears they come from so that's what I
about that was my most recent one cuz it
was one of those things where like we we
we give him medicine two times a day
we're [__] religious about it we're
religious about his naps we put him to
sleep before 8:00 every single day we're
very mindful of it and then when uh Gio
went to go pick him up I was working and
I get the text that taer just had a
seizure it was one of those like your
heart just [__] drops that's sad man
it just feels like the last like year or
two just went down the drain so I was
like damn yeah like teed and then of
course I we go I jump in my car drive to
school and then I see uh Tak getting
carried out and he's kind of has like
this like oh what the [__] just happened
cuz it's like your whole body like
flexing as hard as you can you know so
you kind of like black out a little bit
and then I see like the big ass firet
truck there is obviously the the
elementary school they don't know like
cuz actually what happened he had a
seizure and he fell down a flight of
stairs too get the [__] out of here you
know how this fool tells me he goes yeah
my friend said I fell down the stairs
and I'm like oh you did huh Uncle Joe
dude and what's [__] sweet is the
next day he goes back or two days later
he goes back to school and all his
friends have like notes and drawings
that they all Drew of him they like oh
hope you get better or whatever that's
really sweet it was cute as [__] they
have no [__] idea yeah they all
thought he just fell down the stairs we
were at Red Rock eating dinner and then
one of his classmates was there and was
like Ty like oh [__] and they run
towards each other I like get the [__]
out of the street what are you guys do
it cuz they're just going you know kids
they just Zone in and there's [__]
cars like get the [__] out of there's
like a
hugging all hitting trees they're like y
we got him back on medication and has
been good so far but that was the reason
why we were supposed to be in La ended
up staying in Vegas and then uh Joe came
over to use a hot
tub just to use the hot tub not out of
support nope he's just there to get hot
I don't give a [__] Joe was like can I
just use a hot tub he came he came over
to take Gio out for her birthday because
we couldn't really have whole birthday
thing oh and then I gave her a shirt
which one I I did a 40-year-old version
but then I put Jill's head on
it that's amazing very thoughtful and
sentimental it's kind of a cool shirt
hey so me and Bart teared up in the same
one week yeah for different reasons
you're happy he's sad no same reason no
he's sad yeah me too you were just hot
tubbing it didn't come through you're
hot tubbing though that's sick I wasn't
even invited the first
with Joe you didn't even give me a
chance to deny
you are you the you the only one that
wasn't invited yeah I was the only one
that was you invited wait did Bart not
just tell Joe like yeah Anthony invited
me this [__] whack ass wedding thing
but I said beep no he didn't invite me
either me and Ryan were just you were
for sure out of town when when's this
this weekend what's the date Sunday last
Sunday the day you were out of town what
day were you out of town he was in New
Jersey you weren't in Vegas no he was in
LA it's on Sunday I was here yeah
exactly not Vegas but you could have
gone to Vegas as dud it's crazy I had so
much free time I love going to Vegas we
could have all gone to Vegas I love
driving well surprised we were doing
another wedding just for the JK F you
got wait what time was your event on
Sunday are you for real what time were
what time were you unavailable no no no
no no what time was it was 10:30 in the
morning no it was it was noon 12:30
12:30 is the call time cuz if if B it's
if uh Gio's birthday party thingy was
going on here I guarantee you that whole
house that was having the birthday party
would have drove to Vegas or flu cuz it
would it was ending on
Sunday hey let me just okay it's all
Saab story for him it's all weirdly
selfish for me okay now you're forced me
to give you context okay I invited these
guys and then we really tried to make it
work I know I know you did I was like
are you going to stay on Tuesday or
Wednesday or I know Gio tried really
hard to make over she was the one you
guys could have made it on Su day no
we're trying to make I was H staying
there for until Tuesday or even coming a
day earlier I was trying to make it work
hey Gio Gio felt really bad so she shot
a video explaining the situation so I
already knew about this ta situation she
saw a video but they were she was in the
hot tub bar was sitting in the pool
right and she said yo I feel really bad
yeah why you laughing [__] she's like
she's like I feel really bad so I wanted
to give you a clear explanation T is to
bed right now blah blah blah Bart pops
out P like yo how does it feel like
having friends who are
millionaires
I come out of the pool like this just to
[__] say something I go back into
the wow wow so touching it's so touching
that's a beautiful video for sure so yes
we were chearing about the same thing is
that the second time you cry yes I was
crying on the inside beautiful oh how
heartfelt that's [__] oh my God Ran
that was on Sunday we usually go Nick
but it's Take 6 minutes you know I was
in Vegas on Sunday I was I was here but
I was I was too busy can we focus on the
prompts [__] my pants about the
merch not link not hey you came in
clutch bro we both were almost crying
about that I was like where is every
we're the only ones riding about that
I'm sorry I wasn't picking up I was I
was occupied thankfully Corners are
smart enough know to know how to Google
[__] they found it on their own and then
they put Corners put it on our Discord
yeah they did cor bar do you get
reception in your they legit where he
lives it's dead yeah we really don't get
that good oh wow and I didn't even get a
Miss call from you guys really we I
called you like seven times at least you
guys want the bosses
wait damn man I don't I still haven't I
mean since we've I haven't cried since
the last time we talked about this last
time yeah do you remember I thought we
had this conversation yeah and it was
still the same thing when I beat Final
Fantasy 10 and
2001 really good though really good good
story hey but I cried a lot guys yeah
dude you don't cry dur movies I do
actually yeah yeah I do I do I think the
last time I actually cried in a movie
was probably Guardians the Galaxy 2
they're so good two you didn't CED in
three because that's the father son
moment at the end yeah but he kills his
father spoiler alert sad no no no but
it's not the fatherson of of of ego it's
the [__] the ravager guy oh what oh
the funeral yeah yeah with the with the
them show Sylvester Stallone show cuz
you know the freaking dad son yeah Dad
son kills kills me kills me every time I
watched a a Maverick recently and
there's kind of like the oh top gun
Maverick oh I still haven't seen it oh
what so good I know I keep hearing don't
watch it on a plane watch it on a big
screen with surround sound there's a
fatherson thing in there oh I'm [__]
I'm [__] I'll K you man it's about
Goose too right like that's the father
Son part it's so good kill me for sure I
didn't get emotional with the V kill
part but did you watch Top Gun I didn't
get did you watch top watch Top Gun
recently I watched it back to back I
watched it back to back so you watched
it first to remember yeah yeah by the
way I had never seen Top Gun all the way
through until like 4 months ago what'
you think oh [__] because I always fall
asleep it was just bad timing ien movie
haven't seen it as an adult so I so when
I but still good yeah it left such an
impression on me that when I watched
Maverick I had those oh my God feeling
of like yeah so good the only time I
really cry is movies go ahead man all
right this one's kind of lame but this
is what happened all right so I was
talking to my dad a couple days ago oh
you c a couple days ago some dad [__]
dude it's always father
side um so you know I was just catching
him up with like life stuff what's been
happening and um we're talking like
Tiff's been having a pretty tough year
you know with some health stuff so I was
catching him up to date about that and
then afterwards I was like how you doing
Dad he's like oh man I'm [__] good
he's like I'm [__] great he deflector
too huh yeah he a little deflector but
he's like he's like dude I'm way better
than all the [__] than you're dealing
with like all this [__] on your plate
man like I'm [__] I'm like I'm I'm
fine compared to you the way he puts it
he's one dump on you your life sounds
like a [__] no that's well well cuz you
know it's like uh I think a lot of stuff
has just been non-stop just like back to
back to back to back and then right when
he said that bro I was like all right
Dad talk to you later bro right when I
hung up I was
like like him just saying like oh you
have like you have way more [__] on your
player right now for some reason I sat
and I realized I was like yeah this year
has been kind of [__] nuts like this
is a little weird and I just started
[__] crying for no reason well just
based on like the acknowledge I don't
know just I guess maybe the acknowled
that's what is because it's something
that like like my dad is he doesn't
really like well I guess he does say
things like that but it just the way it
hit me at that moment at that time it
just caught me so off guard where I was
like oh yeah like we are going through
some [__] kind of nuts stuff plus you
haven't really been stopping much to
really think about what you're n bro cuz
I feel like a cuz you're worrying about
it yeah you know so like right when he
said that even me talking about it makes
me like but like I don't know dude he
just [__] caught me and I told Tiff
about it and we just [__] had a big
old cry about it a bunch of you know
idiots but yeah bro I don't know it just
caught me on and it's it's definitely
one of those things that just I it just
blindsided me when did this happen again
like a couple weeks ago I just said a
couple days ago yeah did I say it my bad
couple I meant a couple weeks oh you
said a couple days ago I was like wow we
all crying the same a couple weeks ago
but it was just like just like that and
I was like oh my God does he usually
make you feel like that ain't [__] [__]
is that why cuz it's different from
maybe maybe maybe it's like this time
he's like oh that's that's deep Bro
that's a lot this time he's like hey
that is [__] [__] yeah that's different
from man man up you little [__] that's
nothing no I don't I don't know like he
he usually doesn't I'm really trying to
think about I don't think he does do
that kind of stuff but it made it real
yeah it just it was a contrast I guess
in the conversation damn dude hey
acknowledgement always hits out of
nowhere too he like a sack of bricks
yeah you you are going you guys are
going through a lot but you keep a good
uh you keep a good perspective about all
that stuff in life yeah that's true
you're getting it done still you know I
don't think so you guys my life is
falling apart it was a pun it does feel
like that sometimes though but it's good
though we're all making it work right
guys let's [__] change the
[Laughter]
subject